All right.
What's going on?
I got a couple of reads here before
we start the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast where I just check in on you. Um,
and then I do an interview so I don't want
to interrupt the interview. All right.
Um,
basically becoming Chai Lee rose.
All right. Quip everybody.
The truth is, most of us,
most of us are brushing our teeth wrong,
not for long enough and forget
to change our brush on time.
That's because most brands focus on
selling flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing but not quip. So, Hey Dan,
what makes quip so different?
Men? Well, for starters,
quip is an electric toothbrush.
That's a fraction of the cost of bulkier
brushes while still packing just the
right amount of vibrations to help
clean your teeth. Ladies, keep it clean.
Quip, builts quips built in at
cheese. If the text messages here,
quip bill quips built in timer.
Fuck helps you clean for the dentist.
Recommended two minutes with guided
pulses that reminds you when to switch
sides.
Next,
gotta get one of these.
How does it remind you or at boring?
Uh, next quips subscription
plans are for your health,
not just convenience.
They deliver new brush heads on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just $5, including
free shipping. Worldwide.
Quip also comes with a mount that suctions
right to your mirror and unstick to
use as a cover for
hygenic travel wherever you
take your teeth. Oh yeah.
You gotta cover your brush.
Jesus. And finally, everyone loves quip.
They were named on Oprah's O is,
I love this
named one of Time's best inventions.
And is the first subscription electric
toothbrush accepted by the American
dental association,
not the United Kingdom Dental Association.
That's huge.
Anybody can get their recommendation
because evidently they were asleep at the
wheel, but the American
dental association plus there,
they back there.
They're backed by a network of over 20,000
dentists and hygienists and hundreds
of thousands of happy brushers.
Uh, use quip everyday.
Quip starts at just 25 bucks.
And if you go to get quip.com GE, Ti, Q u,
I p.com/burpee you are
are right now r I g h t,
fucking with you.
You'll get your first refill pack for
free with the quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack free
at [inaudible] dot com slash
burns, spelled g t Q, u, I p.
Dot com slash burr. And uh, lastly,
but certainly not leastly go daddy,
go.
Daddy is the world's largest tech
technological technology platform.
God,
I'm stupid for small business.
Okay,
so if she for small businesses,
okay,
it's a plural business businesses.
Okay,
I started a couple of businesses. You'd
never get a second date. You got to say,
I'm an entrepreneur. It
gets look, sit across.
There was spaghetti hanging on
your mouth. Go. And I said, well,
what am I doing since high school,
while I started a couple
of small businesses as a,
they help regular people get their
businesses running and thriving with just
about everything. You need to
make an I an idea real these days.
That means do it yourself websites.
I can't believe it figured out.
Diy email,
social tools,
and even a business phone app for your
apple or Android may just for a small
business. It says check them
out. They'll do right by you.
Well, there's no links or anything
that she said. I emailed you too.
This is a two parter. Have you
buddy? All right, here we go.
Where's the rest of this? Oh,
that's it. They'll do right
by you. Oh yeah. Go Daddy.
Go daddy.com go daddy.
You could do it buddy.
Um, all right, that's it. Now,
why don't we listen to the interview here
with the one and only Danica Patrick.
All
right,
you ready? All right.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Byrd is time for the Thursday,
Thursday afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast. And I'm just
checking in on you. Who's phone is that?
Is that my phone? Um, I believe it or not.
I am at the Indianapolis Motor speedway
here. And uh, what is it? Bloomington. No,
Indianapolis, Indiana and play
Indiana speedway, Indiana.
And I have a very special guest,
a lovely lady coming to the podcast,
the one and only Danica Patrick. Thanks.
What's going on? You know, just uh,
taking in the sights and sounds.
Hey,
I used to work in a dental office with
my dad by the way. Lovely dentition. Oh,
right out of the gate.
Fantastic.
I don't know why I've been doing the
Invisalign by the way, which I think is a,
uh, it's a great thing.
Kind of straightened out my
teeth down on the bottom,
but they make it seem like they're like,
hey you,
you're just going to wear it for like
three months and then you have like this
night guard thing and I'm
finding that it isn't,
you kind of have to wear these things
for the rest of the time or else you go
right back to have him like snaggle tooth.
So it's kind of annoying.
So they basically get you there.
Like you get so happy with your new
smile and then they lock you in because
they're, you're on the, well, it
must be your fault that your
teeth don't stay like this guests,
you're going to have to wear them
forever and they're going to,
and then I'm going to owe this guy money,
money, money, money. The whole time. I,
I should have known. I
screwed up. So anyways,
I don't think you have probably some what?
Straight teeth.
Oh, money. Yeah. I got a little
bit of money. I go out there,
I tell him my shit jokes or whatever.
We just went around the track in a,
uh, I was saying this, this, this
Camaro, the color of my pubes.
It was a little wimpy that it was a,
a, a, a, a convertible. They know the,
do you feel like that was slowing
you down rather put the top down.
It should be great. We could put
on some jewel, you know? Yeah.
The Sarah McLaughlin, I'm just
rolling around in the, you know,
40 miles an hour.
I've done that one of the time and I was
really nervous with the other person.
But you have like this steely calm
where you were cruising around.
You just sort of like, you
know, I'm trying to make my
stupid, you know, you know,
I'm a dancing monkey.
I'm trying to think my clown jokes.
And you're just looking
over like distracting was
riding distracting as in you
were sort of finding yourself like
feeling and seeing and anticipating and
getting nervous at any point?
Or were you just like rolling?
Like there was a couple of times you came
close to the wall and I was feeling my
face getting pulled in towards the wall
that I was kind of like, all right.
I just kept thinking,
you know,
she's done this a zillion times and she
has to work on Sunday so she doesn't
want to wreck this thing.
And then I was of course also thinking
there's really no rollbar this is just
sort of a very feminine, very
fancy high quality seatbelts. Hey,
how come in Indy car? Like I noticed
this year in, in, in a Formula One,
they have that ridiculous thing that's
now it looks like it's in their,
in their line of sight.
Um,
that little halo thing that
they have going around them,
they're testing the halo, just, you
know, being exposed as dangerous. Right.
So right there,
you know,
there have been drivers killed
through things hitting them, um,
rash parts of the car. Yeah. You
never think that you think, oh,
I gotta actually the cars
have a little wicker on the
front of the cockpit where it opens up
right in front of the steering wheel,
obviously have to be able to
get in. Um, so it's clear,
it's like a plexiglass piece. Um,
and that's what I'm looking through.
Basically when I'm looking
down the front straightaway,
I'm looking at cars just
before I get into the corner.
I'd say I'm maybe look a little past
it to the, to the left when I'm,
when I'm getting into the corner.
But for the most part I'm
looking through it and that,
that thing gets so many like chips
and bugs and all kinds of stuff.
Like I feel like I'm, you know,
drunk by the end I'm like,
I can't see what's going on.
What's the scariest thing like accident
you've been in like that you must at
this point,
the,
as long as you've been doing it had like
a wheel or like I would just think of a
lug nut going, you know, 2000, two, one
at miles an hour coming at you. I mean,
that's got to be
terrifying. Um, let's see.
My first accident in
Indycar was really big. Um,
I ended up going in an ambulance to the
hospital, like, you know, full speed.
And I kept asking the
nurses how if it looked bad.
Apparently I was obsessed with the
idea of like, I'm a, I'm alive,
but it looked really gruesome cool.
And they reminded me that I
had asked them three times now.
And so I didn't realize that because
I was being a little forgetful.
Are you saying like,
did you look bad?
No. Did the accident look bad?
Like what's happened to the car?
Did it look like catastrophic?
Was it exciting? Was it, you know,
did it look like, are
you shocked? I'm here?
You know what I realized when I,
when I came here,
I went to this race and 95 and 96
I was telling you, and you know,
I'm not going to lie. You want to
see an accident? You want to see it.
You probably,
it's probably really annoying.
That's like somebody going to a comedy
club and wanting to see somebody bombed.
But,
uh,
what you don't realize is you think
you want it to be right in front of you
cause you're not thinking of the physics
that like I saw a guy hit the wall
right in front of me,
just really know what this tires,
but it's just like he
hit it there and all the,
all the action was like immediately
a quarter mile down the track.
So you want it to happen like a
half mile up the track or whatever,
however far if you're really going to
see all the, uh, all of the action.
I feel bad saying that to you.
But I did eat.
I mean you want to see an amazing race.
You want to see,
last thing you want to see
accidents. Um, you know,
it's a,
that's why I used to watch
chips back in the day.
It wasn't for the banter
between paunch and John.
It was for like the giant pile up.
I'm probably dating myself.
You probably don't even
remember that show.
I think that show came up probably before
you were born. It is the little tool,
but I have heard of it.
You know what's great about that is they
always have like these freeway pileups
and that would go on for like a minute
and then in the end there was always the
guy that was somehow got air
and went over the top of it.
And if you listen to the sound effects,
he was still on the gas pedal,
which was the funnies. You'd think
you'd hit the brakes at that point
in the air. They, it was in the air. You
know what I had ended up learning with um,
stock car racing cause I
did that for seven years.
Was that the best thing to
do if you were about to,
if you were spinning out or
anything was happening was just mad.
It keep the wheels straight
and keep it floored.
Is Out mad at means.
Oh Matt it put it down to the foot
of down pedal to the metal. Yeah.
What does that like when you drive driving
that fast? Everybody's spending out,
all you see is smoke and you just
hope you're hitting the whole.
Yeah, I mean it's like poking hope, you
know, you're just hoping that they clear,
they clear away and the right, they're
like, you know when they, when cars crash,
especially stock cars and
when there's lots of them. Um,
cause the pileups in stock,
car racing tend to be a little bit
bigger than an Indy car racing. But he,
but either way,
generally the cars,
you don't know where they're going to
go there. Like football's bouncing,
you throw it and it hits
the ground. You're like God,
which toys are going to go?
And that's how it feels when you're like
trying to decide where to go based on
the car.
Like there was a car that crashed in
front of me and practice and it hit the
right outside wall on the right.
And then I wasn't sure if it was going
to cut across the track somehow right in
front of me. So I just kinda
waited, waited, waited, waited.
And then as soon as you
think you're clear, you just
gun it and you just get by.
I miscalculate again, if
they had you miked up, if I
heard you on TV or you just,
you just going fuck,
actually that's exactly what I'm
thinking before anything happens is fun.
It is. It is. Hey, so uh, what's the most,
I'm just jump around here as far as like,
I know you've probably got a lot of shit
for being a woman, you know, in this,
you know, this is a gas where
I was, was stock car was a,
I'm just picturing them being more
sexist because I'm a northerner.
Probably like when you showed up with,
they're like,
what are you going to do here?
Darlin you're going to ride around in
the pace car. Did you get a lot of,
I did get people that said to me like,
how are you going to handle
these big cars? You know,
and I'm like a lot easier because
they have power steering. Yeah.
Plus you're hot, but they're
not harder to drive physically.
They're much less physical to drive.
Was it like one of those Hollywood movies?
Did some guy like say a bunch of sexist
stuff to you and then you beat him and
then the end he had to walk up and be
like, [inaudible] said a bunch of sexist.
I would beat him. You would
in some way, maybe verbally,
but probably start verbally and then I
don't think it would escalate to anything
physical, but I would verbally abuse
them. No. Did that ever happen?
Maybe I don't want you to name names.
Yeah, I'm not going to talk about,
do you remember a quote? Do you
remember a quote, which was what did,
what did you say? Remember there
was a quote a long time back from a,
you've got an f one hat on.
Um,
Bernie Ecclestone's said that
women should be wearing like white,
like appliances and be in the
kitchen or something like that. Oh,
he said that I was stupid.
He's asking, I'm married. It's always,
I think all that stuff's funny, but,
but what it does,
it's drama.
Then you go out and you beat the
person and you prove them wrong. Right.
I don't really take it that personally.
I just don't. It's interesting.
It creates some drama on something. Talk
about, but I don't take it personally.
So now you're going to a,
and I'm really jealous about
this is you're going to retire.
I think that's awesome. I know. I think
it's awesome too. I'm super excited.
I'm like, you know, I there,
I don't know how it feels for you when
you walk out on stage or free do this
with me or I don't know how you
feel when you interview somebody,
but like I'm just excited
to be gone from that stress.
Like I, I'm excited to have, I'm excited.
I'm excited for less polarizing
sort of emotions of, you know,
so,
so happy and so,
so scared or so mad or so sad,
but you can die doing what you do.
Like my job is the most fun job ever.
It's just getting there because all
I think is if I retired I would be,
I would never go to lax ever
again and that's amazing.
I would never have to
connect through Heathrow,
which is one of the
worst experiences I ever
had.
I had to get off,
go get my bag that I checked
and then like get on a bus.
There was like three forms of
transportation to get to a whole,
the whole other side of the airport. And
I just, ever since then I was just like,
I'm never, why do they kiss one
of the kiss? We're standing,
we're right on the finish line is
these tourists, they're kissing.
That's the thing you do after you win
the races. Kissed the bricks. Oh you do?
Yeah, I don't, you know, everybody's
looking at it and then watch,
he's gonna walk across it.
You know,
he went to the men's room
today will autograph it too.
They're probably autographing it
right now. Oh, you can sign it.
I guess you guys just wear it off
after like three laps here. Really?
And they leave with the dream
that it's still there someday.
If you ever go to that race, you're
going to see my name right down there.
Um, so yeah, like uh,
she ran over my name.
How often do you like beat
yourself up after racist?
Oh, what'd you, I should say?
Okay,
Matt. Every one of them
for the most part. Yeah.
I mean you're always thinking about
what you could've done better.
I feel like that's the nature of a
competitive mind of someone very driven.
Like I'm not just
what's, what's the worst as far
as like as far as racing goes,
I would think you're leading with like
two laps to go and then somebody gets
around you,
you run out of gas.
Running out of gas is
not your fault really.
So I would say that's the lesser of them.
Unless they told you to say to you guy go,
when you run out of gas,
does he just leave the whole thing?
Does he immediately get fired? I mean,
I feel like I could do that
fueled and you know, pull the,
pull the fuel fueling hose out
too soon and didn't get it full.
Something like that.
It would be him.
Now if it was your engineers not putting
enough in or not take into account what
was going on and not telling you
to save more, then it was them.
If they told you to save fuel
and you didn't, then it was you.
So it could be a series of,
of um,
Stan, what after the race is like, it's
like, all right, there's a giant finger,
where are we going to point it
a little bit? Yeah, a little bit.
I think there's always, you know,
given the fact that the driver has the
most amount of decisions to make come
race time with passing and restarts and
nailing pitstops getting into your pit
box while getting out of it, you
know, all pit out, just you name it.
Like there's so many different things.
The driver has the most amount of
things that could be their fault.
I would say that generally before the
race it's probably a little bit more on
the team. Um, you know, preparing the
car and then of course working on it,
engineering it and making sure the changes
are good and I'm getting the balance
right for race day and anticipating the,
the weather conditions and you know,
how that will affect the car
aerodynamically. So, um, those,
those decisions become theirs.
But then in the race, you know,
the driver has a little bit
more weight on the shoulders.
What would you have to do and
the pit crew to get fired.
Um, like how many times can you screw up
so that guy short fuels, you're right.
Oh, he probably not going to
get fired till after the race,
but actually that's not true. There are,
there are times where, um, pit crews,
let's say somebody falls out of the race
or sometimes there'll be the middle of
the race. I think I've seen this before
with like Jimmy Johnson or something,
you know, um, they'll swap pit crews in
the middle of the race and just be like,
you know what, we need your picker
of you can take ours. Really? Yeah.
Just switch with different
drivers, different, different guys.
Changing the tires for the four
different driver. It doesn't matter.
Tires or tire. Sorry. Oh, so anytime we
watch or I see somebody run out of gas,
the fuel guys fired. If it's
his fault, probably not. But um,
you know, it's probably a little
like baseball. Yeah. You can only,
you can only can give up so many home
runs before you're going to go back down
to the minors. Yeah. There's only so
many strikes you get against yourself.
All right, so you're, you're
going to retire after this race.
And then you mentioned you have a,
you have your own line of wine.
Is that what you say? I have my own,
uh, my own label. I'd make my own wine.
I make a jungle juice.
No,
I'm a big drinker and a big drinker.
No, when I'm a couple of bottles down,
before you get out there on the track,
just take the edge off, loosen up.
I can't imagine, I don't even want to
take like a Tylenol before I go out,
let alone it seems you just going around
in that rental car. Who's kidding? Who?
Glorified rental car? We just went around
like that. That would be, you know,
you said you were going twice
as fast as this. Uh, you know,
we're going half the speed
of what I'm doing and car.
So it seems like it's a
pretty terrifying sport. Yeah.
Probably don't want to be drunk. Yeah,
I would think that. Yeah. I make wine.
So I bought a, I bought a
property in Napa Valley in 2009.
Smart and,
uh,
just dirt and then planted a
vineyard and it wasn't a vineyard.
You started from scratch, from scratch.
How do you figure out how to do that? Uh,
I had a lot of help from, um, who
was my friend at that point in time.
I'm a wine maker. He is my
wine maker. I'm now, so,
um, you know, I met him at a,
it really goes back to why I started
that falling out on the grapes enough.
No, no, he's still my
winemaker. It's all good.
I met him back in 2006 on
a vacation there and um,
he worked at Contessa at
that point only and uh,
he was, um, you know, he, he was
just having to be there that day.
It was during sort of
the end of crush period.
So it was November time and it was a cool,
nice, beautiful morning. And you know,
the valley's got a little bit
of fog in it and you know,
it's kind of pulling back down into,
towards San Francisco, into the bay. And,
you know,
I'm sitting there on this beautiful
grassy knoll overlooking the vineyard,
rose pedals leading out to
this place. Oh yeah. It's,
it's a, it's not going to get
real funny though, unfortunately.
It's going to get more serious.
[inaudible] pensive high pressure
system moving down. Yeah. So,
um, I just stood there and I
thought, man, this is just so cool.
Like how amazing would it be to
have something like this someday?
And that I in my mind thought
it was wood, most of what, $50 million.
I don't know. What do I need to do this?
And I thought, I don't have
that kind of money yet. And, um,
and then I really believe that
I was like, look, I'm, I'm,
I might have $50 million someday to
be able to do this. But, um, but I,
I started slow,
so went back a couple years later and
looked at some properties and Aaron Pot is
to my winemakers name. Aaron
kind of helped pick it. Yup. So
it's illegal, isn't it? Okay.
That's too many people
grow it in your state.
Then you have too much product and then
you can't ship it out because then it
becomes a federal offense once
you go across state lines.
Why do you know so much about this? I
don't know. I'm not really a pot smoker.
I'll do it occasionally. Like when I'm not
drinking I'll, I just, I just get bored.
I just don't,
I,
I what I like about drinking as I
feel like I earn getting buzzed.
We're, you know, drinking whiskey so he
got to get it down. You know what I mean?
Give me another one where just
like a man at the end, you're like,
I drank all that whiskey. It's not even
that. It's just like, I feel like, uh,
like weed smoking.
It's just like getting fucked up
with like training wheels on it.
It's like you don't have to
worry you just a couple of puffs.
Especially now with the stuff that,
I mean I don't know what the old stuff
was like cause I never tried it to like
my late thirties and um,
all the tests it just puts me,
they'd take two puffs and then you just
kind of like the two seconds I'm like,
oh is kinda cool. And then I just fall
asleep. We're booze. Um, I don't know.
A bit of a slower process. You can
kind of enjoy the growing, the,
the escalation of the buzz too. And I
also know where it's going. I know, okay,
if we controllable,
if I have three of these,
I know kind of where I'm going to be at,
how fast I drink them.
And it's not like you take one sip and
that's one. It's the whole drink. If many,
many sips of enjoyment, you can have a
whole conversation instead of patriot.
I love pass and then all of a
sudden you're like, wait, yeah.
You see and stuff now they, it's,
it's too, you just sit there.
I remember from high school basing out,
right isn't that,
I don't know what it's called.
I thought basically was smoking like coke.
All I know is I got a buddy of mine
and my drugs. I've never done drugs.
You can tell. He can tell you still
got the glow look at me. I look like,
Oh cook a curmudgeon. I got
a buddy of mine, he's like a,
he's a year older than me and he actually
kind of stopped smoking weed cause
he's just like, dude, I miss the
old stuff. You know what I mean?
You just sort of smoked it.
You felt alright. He goes,
now it's just like you take two hits you,
you're like tripping.
And I think that's just because there's
so many people grown it now and they got
to have, there's be like more intense
and stronger than the next. Yeah.
I don't know.
All I know is this just a big thing was
[inaudible] somebody needs to make the
Pinot noir of weed then you know it was
that was that is that you're a little
lighter or something.
You can sort of smoke all evening maybe
or sporadically through the evening.
That's smart. It's a lighter red wine.
You just sold the hell out of that to me.
You know what, my wife
wants to go up there. So
like, what's the difference
between a, a Cabernet, Cabernet,
Cabernet and hello? Marillo.
Well, you know, ruined Merlow.
Who's that guy who played pig vomit in,
uh,
in the Howard stern where I can
never remember people's names. Uh,
I don't remember if he had the same
name as the guy who ran a league.
I can't remember his name,
but remember he said he was in that movie.
It's like I am not drinking
Merlow sideways. Yeah. I
don't remember their names. I,
uh, there's Paul,
Giovanni, Giovanni. Yeah.
So everybody who didn't know shit about
wine like me, I was thinking like, oh,
Merlow is like this. That's like drinking,
drinking any fucking Merlo. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So for this time,
literally affected sales of Marlow and
Tina. No, I went up, peanut oil went up,
what is your f you like a
[inaudible] cab and make a cab.
And then we decided last year to
use the cab to make a Rosacea,
which turned out amazing. Um, we
sold out of that really fast. Um,
so luckily we're gonna be able to make
more next year than we did this year.
And then I have a 70 old blog coming
out as well that I purchased grapes for
that one. And from Knight's
Valley. So. And what is, uh,
what's the name of your won?
Uh, it's a Latin word. So every time I say
it for the first time, people are like,
what? Um, but it's not that hard. It's
a, the name of the wine is called Somnia,
which means dream in Latin.
Um,
because I told you about my little
dream about like having a owning,
of owning the quintessence.
Someday write something like I'd love
to have a winery and I'd love to be able
to do this whole experience and own it
and make it, and yeah, it was my dream.
And so it's a Latin word for dream.
So like insomnia or I get extreme.
You make can be one on my winery.
You can just pop by mine and you know,
we'll be happy to ship
to you whenever you like.
Maybe I'll just do it in my back yard.
I'll have a couple of bushes of grapes
and it'll just make my own wine.
Just podcast.
I got to figure out how I got to figure
out a way where I don't have to go to
the fucking airport every six days.
There's gotta be some kind of technology
where you can see someone somewhere
else. I know you talked to them. I
know, but you can't do that. Well,
we couldn't have written
around Indianapolis Motor
speedway at half race pace if
you weren't here. So if you want the
experiences and you want the connection,
I appreciate you going
the extra weight mile.
Then I did that and I'm horrible at
math. Power, all the extra 1200 miles.
There you go. Oh, from la? Yeah,
whatever. I took the red eye,
I took the still counts. Those miles
still count. What are these are punishing?
What other sports? Sleep or on a, on
a red eye. Can you sleep on airplanes?
Yeah, I can. I do,
but usually you want to get the
window seat so you don't get that tap,
like someone's got to go
up and go to the bathroom.
But I had the ILS snippy me by the
way. You got a weak bladder. I liked,
I just drink a lot of water.
Speaking of, it's a great idea.
You drink a lot of waterway cause
it's really good for you. Oh, okay.
That wasn't challenging. It was
just asking, you've got this weight.
I wasn't trying to pass you. I
work out a lot, so I do a lot.
And then you work out a lot. Is that
what you do? What else do you do? Um,
I sweat and race cars and uh,
you don't want to go just generally a
sweaty person. You're not one of those.
I'm not a, you don't do that. Uh, what
does that stupid thing with Crumb Yoga?
No, the people where they
got to run down the street.
So you know that they're working
out. What do you call that? Fitbit.
What do you call it?
Shit.
It's a new kind of working out where you
run down the street, like a garage door.
They have it open and they're making
all kinds of noise. And then crossfit.
I do that. Well, can you ask
me what are you gonna run down?
Run down the street. Well, because you
needed to accomplish your 400 meter run.
That's part of your workout,
don't you?
Don't you just trying to run by people
sitting down eating brunch to make them
feel guilty. Cause every time I sit
down I get a little eggs. Cheese,
Huh? If you had gotten done with your
workout already and we're at breakfast,
you'd be thinking to yourself,
I've already done that.
But instead you're feeling guilty.
Yeah.
But I would want the person to
know that as they ran by me.
It's a little self reflection moment.
You see somebody working out and it
reflects back to you that you're not,
I think he blamed the victim.
One of us is blaming the victim.
One of us is being a jerk here right now.
And I have to,
only thing that makes me gets me,
I feel guilty when I see somebody
working out thinking to myself,
I could do a two a day.
Right. And I do two a days as
often as I can, but I'm like,
man, I wish I had more time to
work out. What do you, uh, what is,
what is your workout crossfit mostly?
Um,
I do a cross between jumping
jacks, you know, the,
the way that the classes
are usually structured,
they're an hour and the beginning is
some kind of a warm up, some kind of, um,
just shake it out some kind of
maybe a gymnastics move. Um,
and there's pipe position. I already
can't do this workout. Um, uh,
then there's usually an
Olympic lift that you work on,
so deadlift cleans that we got to like
squat all the way down to put a press
back squat. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just [inaudible] driver side.
Then there's the actual workout
part and the workout is between,
oh Jeez.
Anywhere from like five or
seven minutes to 25 minutes.
That's pretty much what the workouts are.
In crossfit,
they usually range around the 12 to 15.
Why would a regular person like me ever
want to put that kind of weight up over
my head, squatting down, blowing out
my knees and then trying to blast up.
Like what is that gonna do for me is don't
you want to kind of like take it easy
on your body? Well, I mean
[inaudible] athlete, I get, you know,
um, uh, weights and um,
impact on some level does actually
strengthen your bones. Who said that?
The people who make the weights because
you got to look to see where it comes
from because like in my lifetime,
eggs have been good for you.
Bad for you and then fruit bad for
you. Yeah. So I feel like cigarettes,
I did you watch what the health
that I watched that and I'm like,
I'm just going to die tomorrow. Oh yeah.
As far as everything that's in our food,
right. Oh God. And I told you sugar
wasn't bad in that one. They're like, no,
eggs are like smoking. And you
know, sugar is just fine. I'm like,
I'm so confused.
Who is putting this shit out there?
That's confusing me. I, that's
why you have to read both sides.
They were sugar is good
for you. No Way. Shooters,
I would've died 10 years ago. Are you
two eggs every morning? I love eggs.
Yeah.
They taste too good to be bad.
What's sent a bunch of skill too good.
When I have animal meat,
so I can't imagine how that's bad.
It's a byproduct of the sun. If it's not
made by the sun, you shouldn't eat it.
I do stand by. That sounds good to me.
I'd have to sit down and work that out.
Like, I mean in animals,
a byproduct of the sun,
they eat the grass that's grown by the
sun. Vegetables made by the sun. Fruits.
Now is your, your uh, you know by,
for the most part is your a or
your cheerios made by the sun.
I love true risk with any refined, but
I put a, I put bananas on top of it.
Made by the sun.
That's better.
That's maybe go for the whole banana
and maybe some almond butter with it.
Oh boy.
It just literally
yesterday. Oh, it's that.
I would definitely want to add to that.
You pasty fat,
fuck or not.
You are pasty but you're not,
you're not the other one because
I'm turning 50 next month,
so I sit at least I got, I got, uh, I
got to get myself in good shape here.
You look good. You look like you're in
shape, so don't, don't, don't look good.
And then you looked away when you look
good and you just sorta look down.
You don't have to look down. And
I was like, you look good. Um,
so I get on the airplane tomorrow with
a bunch of people headed to New York to
do media day for the Indy 500. You have
to leave here and then come back. Yeah,
well actually that was
Monday night. Gosh, sorry.
That was Monday night after practice we
went and so there's food on the airplane
and so we're kind of like handing
it out, you know, here, here, here,
those lazy bastards come out here.
They don't have to leave
where the Superbowl is, right.
Actually every driver went there.
There were like one or two
drivers in each location,
but up there was like 34 drivers out
in America doing media Promo Fund,
spread it out on TV. You
know, it's not going to leave
the state here. Right? Yeah,
yeah, that's true. Well, look, yeah, there
was a lot of local TV done, I'm sure. Um,
so anyway, uh, I get on that,
we get on the plane where Dan in the food
out and then they're handing out like
the dressings and the bread rolls
and they're like, anyone want Brad?
And I'm like, I look back
and I'm like, you know,
there's absolutely nothing in that.
The,
the nothing in that food that's
going to help you. There's zero.
It's like no nutrition. It's nothing.
Other drivers or, no, I told them,
well there was, they weren't, there
weren't any other drivers. They were just,
it was a few guys, few
girls on the plane. No,
it's just people from Nascar or people
from Indy car, my people, whatever.
So anyway, um, yeah, so anyway,
I told the girls that get in
their bread rolls. I was like,
there's nothing in that that's going
to help you. Nothing is going to,
so you were talking about coming into
your kitchen and critiquing your food and
whatever else this is, this is what
I would do. So anyway, I told them,
I went on a long diatribe
of all the things that I,
all my opinions and thoughts and feelings
and they didn't, and you know what?
They didn't eat it. They
didn't need it. There you go.
When we started talking
about Chia pudding in,
somebody had it for breakfast the next
day and they were very excited and I was
like, I'm so proud of you. Well, it's
Chia seeds mixed with some kind of a,
of a milk of sorts. So Chia seeds are the
little tiny little balls. And when they,
when they come in contact with the liquid,
the outs that they puff up,
almost like a chia pet, like a
chia pet. Um, but like, um, like a,
I'm trying to think tapioca
kind of thing where they,
they get like a little gel membrane around
the outside of the seed and I'm so it
becomes more like pudding or just felt
like it was on the $10,000 pyramid.
All these clues and it
wasn't going to guess okay.
This thing and I did it
kind of makes itself bigger.
She just add is it a
grain liquid and it uh,
it's not a grain. It's sound absolutely
discussed putting Chia seeds.
I hate porter.
It's just like,
it's like it was going to be something
in a quit halfway before it got there.
It just feels like it is kind of
boring until you put stuff with it.
Like fruits and you know, Granola
crunchy things. I'm a whole,
I'm a big fan of the, obviously my
life is filled with just dualities of,
you know, super stressful, super relaxed.
Like there's me meditating and then
there's me going 235 miles an hour. Um,
and then like food wise, I like sweet and
salty, combined, crunchy, creamy combined.
So you hate, that. Drives me
nuts. You know the, I wasn't,
I was telling the story of Darryl's
wouldn't want like a salted caramel ice
cream. What's wrong with you? No,
and I don't want like a Karmic says
who would want assaulted ice cream?
Salted caramel ice cream. Yeah,
exactly. It's just because they like you
because I'm going to give
them salt, salted ice cream,
salted caramel ice cream.
It's part of, it's, that's
like a generation gap thing.
Like I went in to get a, uh,
an ice cream the other day.
I was in San Francisco and it's one
of these artists in place. Oh sure.
Like pistachio, goat
cheese, whatever they had,
they had chocolate rose pedal
or something. I was like,
what happened to just
chocolate? What, what is that?
There's no way they put rose petals
in there. That's good. Yeah, they do.
They have a rosewater mist
and all kinds of things.
You can extract the oil from rose petals.
It's very expensive,
so I bet it was the most expensive ones.
Why did you pick it?
I know I ordered mint chocolate chip.
I could just have a mint chocolate chip
and they go, no, it's not in season.
It's not in season. Yeah,
you're making ice cream here.
You're killing anybody that's ever grown.
Men knows that that never dies. Oh.
So it's always,
we'd all creeds and I'm pretty
sure chocolate chips don't ever go.
I don't even have a season other than all
the time. So I needed you then put the,
your your knowledge, I mean a
little earpiece to say that to him.
So I just went to Walgreens and I walked
in and they had a pint of the mint stuff
and I just bought that and I didn't
think what killed me was I didn't want
to eat the whole pint, but now I had to,
cause I bought it, you know,
and I was telling not to waste
Mama, I'm with you. I don't
like to waste food either.
It was really killing me to leave
food on the airplane last night.
And I was like, maybe I'll eat the
salad. Never mind. I'll just leave it.
You just give it to the drug dogs
as you walk out of the airport.
That's what I do. Oh, I pet them. That's
what I do. They still scare the shit out.
I don't have any drugs on
me, so I'm confident and I
can go pet. I don't either.
But what if the dog's having a bad day?
What if it was to just to, it just,
you know, it messed up. Then all of
a sudden it starts staring at you.
Whatever the hell it does. Well, when
it's really mad at won't stare at you.
Have you ever raced in
Singapore? No. All right.
I did a Gig in Singapore and
that's where like they, you know,
they put people to death all the time.
I have never been so terrified
walking through customs.
Like I made sure I look through my
bag like a thousand. I don't even,
I don't even do drugs. But like you
get like the death penalty over there.
I think you'd be able to
get just something abroad
like where you get locked,
docked up abroad. Yeah. That made me
not want to travel. Seriously. Yeah.
But people kept doing dumb shit.
You get the most,
see what the ocean really,
um,
sharing my feelings. No, the
ocean. Um, let's dive deeper.
I would say yeah,
the ocean.
The ocean is my number one fear of
falling overboard and just sitting there
without a sharp object where I could
just stab myself in the neck before the
sharks get there and then kind of
go under and bleed out real fast.
Well yeah cause I was sitting
there looking at it at Hawaii.
Well, I mean what? I don't think it
would sting as much as a tiger shark.
Cause they come up and they take a
bite out of you to see if your edible,
cause they're like, what the fuck kind
of fishes that. Then they take a bite.
I don't know. It wasn't that bad. Kind of
out here in the middle of nowhere. Right.
I think I'll go back in for the second
and you're just sitting there and your
heads above the water. You
take three bites, you know,
if you don't want to eat something. So it
does. I can see what you're saying here.
Yeah. No, it's just, it's
absolutely scared of sharks.
I'm scared of sharks.
I'm scared of that aloneness
of just being out there.
So do you not like being alone period?
Like are you one of those people that
always going to have a buddy around?
I'm a total loner. I love being alone. I
like drinking alone. That's cool. Yeah,
no,
I actually drink
Glenn. You know what, I drank
alone by myself after qualifying.
I had a good qualifying weekend, you
know, come back. It's been seven years.
I qualified seventh,
like as just pretty good.
So I went home and everybody wanted to
go out and do and stuff and I'm like,
I just, you know, like, no.
And I tried to see if somebody wanted
to go and then they didn't text me back,
so I was like,
you know what?
So I sat by myself and drank a
glass of my own Somnia wine cause I,
and then I said to my parents afterwards,
cause I'm,
I'm staying at my parents' house.
So, uh, which was just funny. Um,
I said, uh, Hey, I, uh, I took
some of your wine. Um, but I,
I did one that I took one, at least that
I could replace for you. So I alone, I
know, I know the feeling. Sometimes
it's just relaxing. It's nice.
It gets a little weird when
you go to the second glass.
I'm not going to lie to you.
Yeah. You're kind of like, wait,
what am I doing this for?
You start feeling like you're
in barfly. Um, my buddy,
uh, de Rosa was telling me that he
goes, I love drinking a lot. He made he,
Joe Rosa made it. Okay. So
if he's listening and I want
to thank him, but uh, oh,
getting back to my diet, I
didn't, I didn't get to tell
you this guy, Dean del Rey,
uh, you should have seen him
like maybe three years ago.
He looked like he had been like
the stereotypical, like a cop.
That's what he looked like he'd been,
you know,
just sitting in a cruiser eating bad food,
Tacos and donuts and all of that.
And uh,
he got diagnosed.
Is having like the diabetes that you
can get rid of whatever type that is.
And he just had one. Yeah.
He went on like this.
He actually listened to the doctor.
He read up on nutrition and a,
he lost all of this weight.
He doesn't even look like the same person.
He went from like almost 200 pounds
and he's a little shorter than my,
I am a one was five 10 sometimes I lie,
I lie on my driver's license because
I'm five, nine and three quarters.
I've got to bump it
up. Right. That's okay.
I'm five one and a half and I'd write
that if I could. Yeah. What do you,
what are you saying? Any driver's
license? I five one I think
I'd rather be if I'm going to be short
and I love it real short. Go ahead.
Alright. I'll say fun. He looks
better. He lost a bunch of weight.
He looks amazing and then now he's
done a bunch of us comics on the Diet,
so what?
Every morning I basically,
I'll have like steel cut oats
and then a couple eggs over easy,
whichever Denley you're going to kill me.
Then in between I'll have
like a is z Keel toast,
which is the devil is the way it tastes.
But you just put almond butter and that's
all right. And then uh, then Keenan,
Keenan was the Shit Ma and I say keen
wa I was to say nuclear Kikino Ah,
I say all the grains.
It has a lot of protein and fiber in it.
It's actually a seat.
It's not a grain.
You want to five bucks cause I brought
it up. Let's look it up. What do you say?
Look it. Look it up. Tell me,
I want to know because I
think it's a seed in my diet.
I am missing everything
has been been free.
And so if this turns out to be a
seed and not a grain, I don't know,
even though it's called the
mother of grains. Oh it is.
Listen, once your podcast, once a podcast,
I make a complete ass of myself and I
think that this is going to be okay.
Well we got like six people in here.
They can probably look up whether
or not keen was a grain or a seed.
What's the verdict?
It's a seed.
Bam Patrick.
I'll check Dan and crisp singles.
I swear to God,
somebody give me some milk here that
I can drink for that victory. Um,
look at that. No Way.
I just blew your mind.
I wish you guys could see the look
on her face right now. I love it.
I need to see. I love it. What the
hell? Hey, the proof's in the pudding.
That's a callback sweetheart was
cedar grain keen. Wa is a seed
that harvested from the species
of a plant called goosefoot.
He'd a part of a part of a group of pseudo
cereals making it neither our grain,
neither a serial nor grain and
closely related to spinach and beets.
Then to cereals or grains.
Holy Shit. That's it.
I'm going to have, I'm going to have mind
blown back on the train. I mean, look,
I think you need a glass of
wine right now. Oh my God. I do.
I need a glass of wine and some, you
know, the peanut and a war of marijuana.
Apparently. I gotta be honest
with you. I think this is,
I've been doing this podcast for uh,
coming up on 11 years.
I think this is the first time
anybody's ever learned anything.
This is like a legendary moment.
I know you have one before this airs.
Can you like lay in some triumphant
music in the background and there's no
production quality. But this
is all this says, well listen,
I know you have to get back to racing.
I cannot even begin to tell you what
an as far as like a fan of racing it.
Like what a thrill that was.
Every time we went down the straight away
and I saw whatever you call that thing
where they show the leaders and all
that. The tree there. I mean this is a,
it's incredible.
Thank you so much for doing that.
I'm definitely going to get
some of your wine. Can people,
you've got a website where they
can order it. Somnia wine.com.
You got to spell it for my listeners.
So em and I u M it's phonetic.
It's just a weird word. Some neat. Um,
he really didn't spell it for them.
On the front of the bottle, on the front
of the bottle there is the, the, the,
the breakdown like syllable by syllable
is underneath the words so that people
can, can find out some to get, I'm going
to definitely going to get some of that.
And what should I go with? What do
you think? Get the peanuts cab? No,
I don't make it. I don't really
like Fino actually. Okay.
I'll get the Rosedale cause I love
a rosy in the, no bonk, you know,
wrapped round it all off.
You've got, you know, summer,
Spring and fall and winter covered.
I'll drink them all by myself in my hotel
room tonight. All right. Danica Patrick,
everybody, uh, about to retire driving
her last race. I'm so happy for you.
You know that you, you're, you're doing
what you want to do. Yeah. That's awesome.
I got relaxed listening
to your retirement plan,
hosting the SBS and I'm hosting the SBS
told me all the keys to the kingdom for
that one. Yeah. Having
never hosted in award shows.
You said make sure you drink
before you go out there,
but the camera for yourself
take a shot at James. So if I,
if I fall or if I just completely
lose my train of thought.
Um, basically if I end up saying boom,
goes the dynamite, it's because I'm drunk.
There you go. Just relax,
smile. Have a good time.
Make Fun of yourself. If a joke bombs,
make fun of the fact that it bombed.
Just be, be in the mall. You're going
to be great. You're going to be great.
And at some point I hope, ah, me
and my wife can get up. What does,
what does the name of the wine?
I'm a booze guy.
Somnia Napa Valley.
That's where the wine is. Everybody. All
right, thanks for listening to podcast.
Hang in there.
We've got a little love a little music
here and then we'll have a half hour of
greatest hits from the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast earlier my life.
So anyways,
I go,
I go to the airport and I'm taking
the red eye, taking this 10 55 flight.
No one fucking stop. Cause
that's how I do it. All right,
I'm on a good plane.
Why would I want to get off it and switch
and roll the dice and get on another
one? You know, let's
just fucking get there.
When it, when I drive up to San Francisco,
I don't pull over and fucking, uh,
Burbank and then get hit new, another
cup. We get it bill. All right.
Okay.
So I get on the fucking
plane, right? I use my miles,
bumped myself up like a fancy
person. You know, maybe,
maybe I invented the cheesecake factory.
People are thinking and then they
see how I'm dressed and I go, oh no,
he didn't vent that cheese cake factory.
Um,
and I go to go to sit down in my
seat and I go to set my bag down.
I was going to set it
down right in front of me.
And the nice fellow sit next to me,
he goes,
why don't you stick it in
the middle of this room?
And he moved his bag out of
the way. I'm like, all right,
this guy's a solid dude or whatever.
And then all of a sudden the waitress
comes by a stewardess, whatever.
She comes by, flight attendant, whatever
the fuck you supposed to call him,
she comes up and she, uh, could I get you
juggling to Drake? And I was like, yeah,
can I get out? Let me get a water please.
I said, no, ice what? However you make it,
stop acting like it's a fucking
Martini. It's war, right?
Just give me a water
with ice. Thank you. Um,
and the, the guy next to me, he orders
it doers. Neat. No, I, no nothing.
Just put it in there. So they bring our
drinks. All right. And I'm really thirsty.
So I start sucking mine down
and he just throws his back.
Like it's nothing like fucking John Wayne
right before he's going to turn around
and beat up three guys, three
mustachioed guys in the 1930s. Right?
So, um, I'm just sitting there and
everybody's getting on the flight and now,
and I'm looking around at the passengers,
you know,
fucking doing whatever I'm doing.
And all of a sudden the guy next to me,
Mr doers goes to me. Uh, he
goes, excuse me? He goes,
are you afraid to fly? And I
looked at it, I was like, why?
He goes, are you afraid
to fly? And I go, no,
no, I'm not. And he goes, because all
right, but you know, it's, he goes,
it's okay. It's okay to tell
me if you're afraid to fly.
And it's immediately getting weird. And
I'm like, no, I'm not afraid to fly.
And then I'm thinking in my
head, wait, is he afraid to fly?
And that's why he's drinking
the way he just drank.
And now he's hoping that I'm going
to be afraid to fly. So he, you know,
he just wants to open up. That's what
I'm thinking. And I get, I'm like, yeah,
no,
I'm not afraid to fly.
Yeah.
And he won't leave it alone. He goes, all
right, cause you know, you're, you're,
you're fidgeting,
you're looking around at other passengers.
Okay.
And I'm sitting there looking at it like,
is this guy fucking serious? And I go,
no. I go, I'm not afraid to fly.
So now I'm like, fuck this guy.
I'm not talking this guy for the rest
of the flight. This guy's weird man.
It's like a 30.
Just get paint a picture.
He's like 32 year old winery in shape,
but like,
why are we white dude, he's got a
skully cap on with fucking glasses.
Um,
you know,
and uh,
okay.
He goes,
uh,
like there's like a minute of silence
and people still getting on the plane and
then he goes, hey, sorry
about that. So we, we just,
we just got off on the wrong foot. He's
like, my name's So-and-so. He goes,
what's your name? And then I'm thinking
in my head like, what's my name?
My name is frank.
I wanted to give him like a by just
some reason I just wanted it's bill.
And he goes, oh, hey bill
Nico's nice to meet you.
So we shake hands and I'm just looking at,
I don't have any poker face.
I'm looking at the guy like,
what the fuck is your problem?
I'm not even trying to not,
I'm not trying to be pleasant.
I'm already done with this guy. So then
the guy goes, oh, hey bill. He goes,
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
Right?
Like he's fucking interrogating me and I,
okay.
I'm like,
is this going to fucking serious?
And I start doing the
math in my head going,
when is this guy like an air marshal or
something? And I'm like, no he's not.
He's fucking slamming bows over here.
Fuck this guy.
So I just go, I go, look, I don't, I
don't have to answer your questions.
That's it. And I just look
straight forward. He goes, okay,
now I'm concerned. Okay, I am
concerned and I'm looking at,
I'm like concerned about what he
goes, you're fidgeting your, you,
you have issues with other
passengers and blah blah blah blah.
He's such a Peyton like, like, dislike.
He's been, I don't know what the fuck,
like psychologically breaking me down.
All right, so now at this, by this point,
they've closed the fucking the door to
the fuselage and we're starting to taxi.
And I just finally look
at the guy and I go,
yeah,
I go, you know, I came up
with the five one point.
I literally stick my hand out cause he
kept saying I was nervous and I stick my
hand right in front of his
face and I hold it level. Oh,
that's what I did the first time. Yeah.
I hold it level. I go, I'm not nervous.
And he goes, well, anybody can do that.
And that's when I was like, fuck this guy.
I'm not talking to the guy. Sorry, the
story up. Then Denny Denny came back,
got my name. Now he's going, why are
you going to Indianapolis? And I find,
look at them. I say, listen pal, I'm
drinking waters. You're drinking doers.
Okay, there's no issue over here.
And then he goes, it wasn't doers.
What she gave me wasn't doers really.
What was it? Some sort of spy juice.
You fucking jerk off this point.
I want to punch him right through his
fucking stupid wirey glasses. Right?
So he's going like you
looking around hostels.
And I said something that just ticked
him off. I was just sad, dude. I go,
I don't have to answer your questions. All
right, leave me alone. And then he goes,
uh, he goes to egos. He
starts going like, okay,
now I am really concerned right now. He
goes, why are you going to Indianapolis?
And I just look at him, you
know, when I stopped doing,
I start doing like this Ryan Gosling,
you know that little smirk that fucking
Mona Lisa smile he has is he smirks his
way through all this fucking movies.
I do go. I go full on Ryan Gosling.
Now I'm not talking to this guy and I
just keep looking at him and I give him
that little half a smirk and I
just shake my head. That's my game.
Now this is Mike.
It's like if you're going to be a Dick
Right now with your fucking delusional
authority, right? That
you're going to say like,
we're in fucking Guantanamo and
you're going to waterboard me. Ah,
there's no water, there's
no board. Go Fuck Yourself.
Here's my smart and I'm just going to
shake my head at you like you're a fucking
pathetic human being. This is what I'm
doing, right? And this is the funny thing.
I'm such a Dick. All they have to
say to the guys, I'm a comedian,
I'm going to do a sold out show there
and that would make them back off,
but I'm a dick. I'm like, fuck this
guy. I want to see where this is going.
So now he's all fucking amped up
and he starts droppingF , you know,
you see saying the f word, he's sitting
there going, if you don't, he goes,
if you don't fucking answer my question
right fucking now I'm going to hit that
call button was sitting in a taxi
and down the fucking getting in line,
I'm going to fucking hit
this fucking button if you
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I'm just fucking
Mona Lisa smile smirking,
just shaking my head like you
are a fucking retard, right?
So now he sees saying the f word so much.
The lay who sitting in front
of me diagonally in front,
right in front of him,
turns around and looks at us and
now my heart's racing. I'm like,
where's this going?
This is going to be great.
I am a hundred percent fucking innocent.
This guy's drunk and I think
he's going to hit that button
and he's going to hit that button.
What's going to happen, right?
I want to see what the pilot looks like.
Let's see where the fuck this is going,
right? So he goes, if you fuck you,
he starts me such bringing
his hand up to the button. Go,
I'm going to hit that button.
You don't have to go fucking do it.
I'll hit that button and I'm sitting there
smirking, and I'm thinking in my head,
go ahead and hit the fucking button.
Let's see what happens.
Let's see what happens, right? So finally,
now he wants to hit the button
and he can't fucking find it,
and it's an in defense of him. I couldn't
find it either. I was looking up there,
I half wanted to hit it myself.
Then he finally,
he finally finds it and he hits it right?
And now I'm just like,
Holy Shit. What's going to happen? And
he's sitting there going, yeah, Huh?
You want to fucking play this game and
you want to fucking play this game.
And I'm surprised.
I mean it took like fucking like 30
seconds before a flight attendant,
the one who gave him the booze,
which evidently wasn't booze comes over.
And at this point we're like doing
that shit where we're behind the plane,
we're almost ready to take off,
like we're pulling up and
then stop and pull it up.
Then stopping as planes are
taken off. So she goes, yeah,
what's the problem over
here? And he goes, ah,
I'm not comfortable to fly with
this guy. This guy, he's fidgeting,
he's looking around at
other fucking people.
Blahblahblahblahblah he's
doing all this thing right.
And then the stewardess looks at me and
I'm just sitting there fucking my little
smart, just shaking my head that just
looking at just shaking my head. Like,
this guy's out of his fucking mind.
I don't say a word.
And this guy goes on and on and on about
his fucking psycho babble about having
this security risk.
So she goes to, so she goes, okay. Um,
any other passengers?
Have you noticed anything?
She talks to anybody first class,
this
is there. Anybody notice
anything odd about this guy?
And The lady who was sitting
right in front of the dude,
Dagley's from me turns around. She goes,
yeah, I've been listening to this guy,
bright berating this other passenger.
She's on my side and I haven't said
a fucking word. This is a great,
and I'm just sitting there smirking.
Then they'll let it,
it sucks for me and I shrug my shoulders
like, I don't know what to tell you.
So finally she said, sir,
do you have anything to add
to this? I just said, look,
I'm just a guy trying to go to
Indianapolis. This guy over here,
he starts slamming his doors. I kind of
felt like a rat when I said that. I go,
he's slamming his doors. Next thing you
know he's dropping the f bomb to me.
Then I'm thinking, oh fuck.
I just said bomb, right.
Fortunately nothing happens.
So now another fucking,
the male stewardess comes over right
now. He's going like, what's going on?
And the captain of the fucking,
now at this point, we've
pulled over in the plane,
has stopped 250 people trying to get to
Indianapolis and jerk off over here who
can't hold his fucking alcohol, who
just watched a person of interest every,
every August. Evidently I have no
fucking idea. Now the plane is stopped,
is fucking jerk off,
has stopped the plane
interrogating a Goddamn comedian.
Like I'm in the fucking Taliban and
like he works for the CIA, right?
So now we're just sitting there
and the captain is up front in the plane,
like saying to the storage
is going basically relaying,
do I really have to
fucking come back there?
This is the last flight of the night.
Is there really a God damn problem?
And that was the vibe. And they finally
said to the doe, sit next to me,
are you going to be okay to fly with him?
And at that point it appeased his fucking
ego that he was somehow in control.
And he goes like, you know what? Okay,
it's fine. It's fine. It'll be fine.
It'll be fine. So they go, okay,
so now the plane's going
again and now what?
Now we fucking come around and
he's sitting there fucking,
he's in my ear and at this point I am lat,
like to fucking laugh.
He had me doing the podcast. That's what
I'm doing. And he's sitting there going,
I, he goes, you know what? I'm glad.
I'm glad you, I hope you fucking do.
I hope you fucking try something.
I'll be fucking try
something one more up there.
I really hope you fucking try something.
And I'm just fucking like gut
and laughing. Shake him at like,
what are you going to fucking do to me?
What are you gonna do to me?
How are you gonna Punch me in the face?
You fucking wire jackass.
You get fucking glasses on.
You know that's a federal offense.
You're going to go to jail if you do that
or something. I don't know what, right.
So I'm just in a fucking laughing
at the guy going, I actually,
at one point I put my fucking little
eye pillow thing on. Do you know like
going to sleep? Oh, I had that out too.
When the stewardess was talking to me,
I was like,
putting it on is this total mind fuck.
Like I don't know what this guy is.
I'm just trying to go to Indianapolis.
I'm going to sleep. And um, so I got,
I got my fucking thing on, right as
he's sitting there threatening me,
just I was going with total passive
aggressive. It's like, dude,
I'm so not concerned with
you. I'm literally putting
a blindfold on. All right,
so this fucking guy, he
starts going, he goes,
hey. He goes, you think you
fucking one this, you do, you
fucking won this. He goes,
my, you know, my dad is my
dad. He started seeing his dad,
some major CEO in Indianapolis. Doesn't
sound like a fucking made up story.
I swear to God, this is all true.
He Goes, Mike, my dad is some,
a major CEO in Indianapolis and
I will have you fucking arrested.
And The lady turns around again,
how have you fucking arrested the second
we get on the ground? I'm thinking like,
for what? For what? Sitting here,
you fucking loser. Learn how to
hold your alcohol. All right?
And he starts describing the view. Then
I'm going to have, when I go to jail,
like some fucking law and order
episode. Oh, you're going to love it.
You'll be able to see Lucas
oil field and by by the bar.
And I'm just sitting there cracking up
laughing and then there's this pause,
right? And I'm thinking finally he finally
shut the fuck up. It's like a three,
four minute pause. He finally just gave
up because I wasn't giving them anything.
I was just laughing and shaking my head.
I was being a dick to him.
I was cause I was enjoying it.
And then there was like a three minute
pause and then all of a sudden he just
goes,
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
So we're like 20 minutes into the flight
and am I going to be honest, he's,
my adrenaline was so going during all
of that because I knew I didn't do
anything wrong,
but I thought we were literally going to
go back and it was going to be fucking
cops there. And if like, if, if, if,
if the fucking stewardess or the pilot
asked me who I am and where I'm going,
I'm going to tell them I respect your
authority. You're just some Jay, I don't,
you don't have any authority.
I don't have to answer your questions.
It was pro was one of the most
fun experiences I've ever
had with another human being.
Like when somebody thinks that they
have power and you know, they don't,
and all they can do is try just keep
bluffing and raising their voice and start
cursing at you.
And if you just start laughing at them,
the look on their face
is fucking priceless. So
the last thing he said, he said, why are
you going to Indianapolis Bill? Right?
And I fucking started howling,
just fucking holding my stomach,
shaking my head
and with my fucking eye
pillow thing on right.
And I know I'm going to get a ton of
shit that I wear one of those eye,
they're fucking underrated.
Get the one at Brookstone where it's
literally a pillow. I'm telling you,
you could fall asleep 12 noon
facing the sun. It's awesome.
So anyways, like after he asked me
what, what, you know where you're going,
Bill,
you like there was like a 10 minute,
like probably 10 minutes had gone by and
I can't fucking sleep because it's so
fun. And to me I can't wait to
tell the story. Every comic I know,
I can't wait to try it on stage to
see if it's funny or whatever. Uh,
so finally I just like fuck it.
Maybe I'll just get on my computer and I
yeah,
bring up my eye pillow and I like,
I got to look at the guy cause I know
he's fucking staring at me waiting for me
to do something right.
So I lifted it up,
I get my fucking Mona Lisa smile going
and I look over at the guy and dude,
he is fucking passed out.
He looked like he got shot.
He was sitting there like his head was
just hanging straight down and anytime
the plane move like his head was,
I mean he got knocked out for
the rest of the fucking flight.
All fucking uh, what's Matt
Damon's character? Jack Ryan.
Hold fucking Jack Ryan over here is just,
you know,
the sky marshal the fucking booze bag
and God knows what else he was on.
He was just completely out passed out
for the rest of the fucking flight.
And this is what I want you to dick. I am.
I was having so much fun with this guy.
I start,
I can't sleep.
So I start slamming waters because I want
to have to get up and take a piss just
to see if this guy's going to freak out
because this security risk is getting up
and there's,
the joke was on me,
he never regained consciousness and
then I really had to take a Piss,
but I'm such a stubborn fuck.
I was holding it because I wanted to
make sure he was awake when I got up
because I was going to give them a little
smirk and then I was going to get up,
see, hit the call button
again. Um, but he did,
he didn't wake up till
we hit the ground and um,
and it's funny. Then he woke up
and it was like four hours later.
So now he had kind of slip off
whatever the fuck this guy was on.
And I'm sitting there smart and wait
for the guy who started talking him,
he won't look at me and I,
and I think at that point
he kind of fucking realize
that maybe he got a little,
uh,
a little extra little too patriotic.
So we stop,
we stopped at the gate and
everything and we're going to get up.
So I grabbed my shit.
I get up and I'm just kinda looking
at him and he won't look at me.
And then the lady who was sitting in front
of me had this big smile on her face.
She goes, hi. She goes, how you doing?
I don't want good. I go that. I go,
that was an interesting one.
And I said it really loud.
So the guy heard and he
didn't say anything and to,
this is what he did to try to save face.
His pillow was kind of stuck behind this
kind of stuck behind his shoulder and
like a weird place. So he was
frustrated with it. So he,
he ripped it out from behind him and
kind of threw it down on the floor when
he tried to do some caveman grunt
to try to still have some sort of a,
I don't know what. So, so that was
my flight to Indianapolis people.
Um, you know what, how, how far
into the fucking clock has diary?
That was a long thing.
It was a long fucking story here.